[Aplausos]
Pese a que inició hace tres meses la
revuelta en Irán no se ha debilitado y
el régimen ha endurecido su represión el
lema mujer vida libertad sigue resonando
tras la muerte de maksamini detenida
tres días antes de su fallecimiento por
la policía de la moral por llevar el
velo de manera supuestamente inapropiada
a la vanguardia de esta revuelta los
estudiantes iraníes que se organizan de
manera informal en internet en ausencia
de un líder como en estas imágenes en
una universidad de Terán
a los estudiantes se unieron en su lucha
minorías étnicas iraníes pero también
comerciantes y trabajadores que
respondieron a las convocatorias de
huelga general lo que debilitó aún más
la economía del país
Durante los últimos días los iraníes
también han celebrado marchas
silenciosas por todo el país como aquí
en
el 4 de diciembre Un anunció hizo que el
gobierno iraní diera Un paso atrás el
fiscal general anunció la disolución de
la policía de la moral la misma que
había detenido a maxa a mini pero tras
el anunció la represión va en aumento
desde el inicio de la revuelta el 16 de
septiembre entre 14 y 17.000
manifestantes han sido detenidos las
fuerzas de seguridad y arañas han matado
a más de 400 personas entre ellas unos
60 niños un seis personas han sido
condenadas a muerte dos ya han sido
ejecutadas
de 23 años primer manifestante ahorcado
en público según amnistía internacional
varias decenas de iraníes más podrían
correr la misma suerte desde el comienzo
de la revuelta miles de civiles han sido
detenidos sin embargo algunos han sido
liberados como esta joven iraní de 17
años que en estas imágenes está ya de
alegría al salir de prisión confianza se
enfrentaba a la pena de muerte por
último 47 periodistas están encarcelados
en Irán tres veces más que el año pasado
en las redes sociales los estudiantes
cuelgan fotos de cuerdas está va
acompañada de un mensaje la esperanza no
será ejecutada